welcome everybody special welcome to all
of our new audio podcast subscribers
record week uh yesterday was the best
day the audio podcast has ever had
uh unbelievable and want to welcome
everybody who is
carrying the show around with them in
their pocket i guess as i call it
we have so much to talk about and
because there's been so much to talk
about we really have not spent as much
time as we should be spending on
coronavirus
and i would be doing a disservice to you
if i didn't do that today
and remember donald trump said that
there would be no more talk of
coronavirus
on november 4th because it was merely
political trump said everything was
going to open on november 4th
trump said there would be no more
discussions of an urgent pandemic on
november 4th of course
it's been the exact opposite in fact and
joe biden has fortunately immediately
formed a coronavirus
task force which has already met we have
continued to talk about it
and coronavirus is completely out of
control there's
there's no other way to say it it's
completely outrageous dystopian numbers
when you look at them
and this administration is done so our
approach going in is
if we don't do something and if
governors don't do something until joe
biden is inaugurated
trump is done trump is in a fragile
emotional state as philip rucker will
later tell us
he is done with the virus now meanwhile
the united states hit a record number of
hospitalizations
this week we passed 1 million new cases
in just 10 days
the first 10 days of november this is
exploding and the first two spikes in
april
and july when you look at a case graph
they barely even look like spikes the
current third spike during which we're
seeing
even 140 000 new cases per day makes
those
early spikes in april and july look like
little mole hills and of course they
were major spikes at the time
and dr anthony fauci warned us about
this months ago
dr fauci said you could see a hundred
thousand cases a day in the fall
and when we got to 35 000 in april and
they started declining
a lot of people didn't believe dr fauci
but he was right and if anything he
wasn't
aggressive enough because we are seeing
140 000 per day
no sign of a slowdown deaths are also
spiking we've now had two days in a row
with right around
1500 deaths per day that's a 911 every
two days and those numbers are going to
go higher
deaths today remember are based on cases
two to three weeks ago two to three
weeks ago
we had half the cases that we do today
so in two to three more weeks
we could be seeing 2 500 deaths a day we
could be seeing 3 000 deaths a day
not out of the question we could be
seeing a 911
every single day right now 49 out of 50
states
are increasing in cases 30 states
set new records just this week and like
i said
hospitalization there were a couple
weeks there
where cases were going up
hospitalizations were not yet up
um hospitalizations have now reached a
pandemic high
and are clearly going higher since 140
000 more people tested positive
yesterday
and the day before um in i'm trying to
think what state it was i believe it's
in one of the dakotas
uh the governor has announced that oh
must well must be north dakota because
south dakota is christy gnome and this
was a male
governor i believe it's the governor of
north dakota i should be more prepared
i'm going from memory
said hospitals are now full and they
are going to need nurses to keep working
even if they have coronavirus
nurses with coronavirus in again i
believe it's north dakota
have been cleared to keep working even
when they test positive because things
are that out of control
we need leadership i know it's easy to
say listen david every country is having
a spike
every country is seeing a spike remember
that
many countries are on spike two right
now so when we look at other countries
and we see
they are also having record numbers they
are having record numbers rel related to
spike number one
many of those countries suppress the
second spike all summer
and they are now getting to the second
spike we're already on spike number
three
and spike number three is putting spike
number two to shame
all these other countries are only now
getting to spike number two
and um when we say everything is spiking
understand that we are a f i'm not
calling them waves because we never
really got out of wave one but
spikes we are a full spike ahead of most
of these countries and it is an
absolute and total disaster cdc now
issuing recommendations about
thanksgiving and those recommendations
are have thanksgiving outside
now in much of the country it's not
possible uh the dakotas minnesota
northern michigan you know
it gets very very cold here in
massachusetts
it may well be a high of 30 by the time
of thanksgiving even though it's been
unseasonably warm so a lot of people i
know
are either not doing thanksgiving or
they are doing a drastically
reduced thanksgiving i know a few folks
who said
we we're doing like a six-person
thanksgiving and what we've agreed to do
is
everybody's getting tested on monday of
thanksgiving week
doing nothing for the rest of the week
and assuming we all get
negative tests we'll do an indoor thing
hopefully with windows open sitting far
apart on thursday
um thanksgiving has the remember we
didn't have thanksgiving
during the pandemic last year and
thanksgiving could be
a real super spreader event nationally
i think i'm doing nothing on
thanksgiving that's the latest for me i
think i will be reading and
uh catching up on some documentaries
that i've been i've been meaning to but
it is looking
very very ugly privacy.com is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you five
dollars
just for using their free service at
privacy.com
pacman privacy is a service i've been
using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can
set spending limits freeze them delete
them whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged
in the future if you're ordering food
over the phone why do i need to give a
restaurant my real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy dot com
slash pacman